♪
>> DOES THAT SEEM LIKE AN ACT OF
DOMESTIC TERRORISM THAT YOU OR
YOUR JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OUGHT TO
BE INVESTIGATING?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT, AND I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
SUPPORTS AND DEFENDS THE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT OF PARENTS TO
COMPLAIN AS VOCIFEROUSLY AS THEY
WISH.
LIKE YOU, I CAN’T IMAGINE ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE IN WHICH THE
PATRIOT ACT WOULD BE USED IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF PARENTS CHANGE
ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN, NOR CAN I
IMAGINE A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE
THEY WOULD BE HABLEED AS
DOMESTIC TERRORISM.
-- LABELED AS DOMESTIC
TERRORISM.
MARIA: REALLY?
WELCOME BACK.
THIS WEEK BLOCKBUSTER EVIDENCE
ALLEGEDLY CONTRA A DISTRICTING
THAT CLAIM BY A.G. MERRICK
GARLAND UNDER SWORN TESTIMONY
AFTER WHISTLEBLOWERS REVEALED
THE FBI HAD, IN FACT, LABELED
DOZENS OF INVESTIGATIONS INTO
PARENTS WITH A THREAT TAG
CREATED BY THE FBI’S
COUNTERTERRORISM DIVISION.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW, THE MAN
WHO LED THE QUESTIONING FOR THE
GOP, JUDICIARY COMMITTEE RANKING
MEMBER OHIO CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN.
HE’S ALSO TO HAVE OF -- AUTHOR
OF THE BOOK, "DO WHAT YOU SAID
YOU WOULD DO."
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN, THANKS VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU, MARIA.
MARIA: YOUR REACTION FROM THE
WHISTLEBLOWER THIS WEEK.
DID A.G. GARLAND MISLEAD YOU
THERE?
>> IT SURE LOOKS LIKE HE DID
BECAUSE THE VERY AP A RAT
DISCUSS THEY PUT INTO MOTION
WITH HIS MEMO THAT SETS UP THE
LINE FOR REPORTING, THEN THE
E-MAIL THAT WENT OUT TO FBI
AGENTS ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
THAT PROCESS WAS USED TO GO
AFTER MOMS AND DADS IN MORE THAN
TWO DOZEN CASES.
AGAIN, HE SAID HE WOULDN’T USE
THE COUNTERTERRORISM MEASURES OF
THE GOVERNMENT TO GO AFTER
PARENTS, BUT IT LOOKS EXACTLY
LIKE WHAT HAY DID.
AND GOD BLESS THESE
WHISTLEBLOWERS WHO CAME FORWARD.
MARIA, IN ONE CASE THEY WENT
AFTER A MOM WHO WAS IN THE GROUP
MOMS FOR LIBERTY WHO ACTUALLY
OWNED A FIREARM WHICH YOU’RE
ALLOWED UNDER OUR CONSTITUTION,
AND THE PERSON WHO REPORTED HER
SAID THOSE WERE THE REASONS THAT
SHE REPORTED THIS PERSON, AND
THE FBI NIFGHTED.
INVESTIGATED.
SO THIS IS SCARY STUFF.
ONE OTHER THING, THINK HOW
QUICK, THINK OF OF THE SPEED AND
THE INTENSITY WITH WHICH THE FBI
AND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DID THIS.
THE SCHOOL BOARD ASSOCIATION
SENDS A SETTER -- LETTER ON
SEPTEMBER 29TH, FIVE DAYS LATER,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SENDS A
MEMORANDUM SETTING UP THIS
SNITCH LINE, AND 16 DAYS AFTER
THAT THE FBI SENDS OUT THE
E-MAIL ESTABLISHING THIS THREAT
TAG LEVEL.
THAT -- LABEL.
THAT ALL HAPPENED IN 22 DAYS.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN -- I DON’T
KNOW IF ANYONE’S EVER SEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MOVE THAT
QUICKLY ON ANYTHING BUT, BOY,
WHEN IT COMES TO CHILLING SPEECH
AND GOING AFTER MOMS AND DADS,
THEY OPERATED AT RECORD SPEED.
MARIA: WELL, IT SEEMS THAT THEY
ARE GOING AFTER ORDINARY
AMERICANS AS WE SPEAK.
NOT JUST PARENTS, YOU’VE GOT
PEOPLE LOCKED UP RIGHT NOW IF
THEY CAME ANYWHERE CLOSE TO
WASHINGTON FOR THE JANUARY 6TH
SITUATION.
YOU WERE SUBPOENAED, I WANT TO
GET YOUR ANSWERS TO THIS, THE
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE IS
SUBPOENAING YOU, KEVIN
McCARTHY, THREE OTHER
REPUBLICANS ABOUT YOUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
HOW YOU RESPOND?
>> WELL, I MEAN, AGAIN, I GO
BACK TO WE’VE GOT RECORD CRIME,
RECORD INFLATION, MOMS THAT
CAN’T GET BABY FORMULA, OTHER
MOMS WHO ARE BEING INVESTIGATED
BY THE GOVERNMENT, DOJ IS COMING
AFTER THEM X THIS ARE
RIDICULOUS, PARTISAN COMMITTEE
IS DOING THE THINGS THAT THEY’RE
DOING.
MARIA, THERE’S A REASON SEVEN
OUT OF TEN OF OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS THINK THE COUNTRY IS ON
THE WRONG TRACK.
THE GREATEST COUNTRY -- 70% OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK THE
GREATEST COUNTRY IN HISTORY’S ON
THE WRONG TRACK BECAUSE OF WHAT
THEY’RE SEEING FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND DEMOCRATS.
SO THIS COMMITTEE, AGAIN, MOST
RIDICULOUS ARE, PARTISAN
COMMITTEE I’VE EVER SEEN.
FIRST TIME IN AMERICAN HISTORY
WHERE THE MINORITY LEADER, FIRST
TIME IN THE HISTORY OF THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES WHERE THE
MINORITY LEADER WAS NOT ALLOWED
TO PUT ON A SELECT COMMITTEE
THAT INDIVIDUALS HE OR SHE
SELECTED.
WE HAVE CAUGHT THEM LYING ABOUT
EVIDENCE BECAUSE, AGAIN, WE’LL
HAVE TO SEE, BUT I THINK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND JUST
HOW RIDICULOUS THIS, THIS
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE IS.
MARIA: WELL, I MEAN, IS LIZ
CHENEY SPEARHEADING THIS?
IF WAS SHE THE ONE WHO WAS
LEADING THE UNFORTUNATE R EFFORT
TO -- THE EFFORT TO HAUL YOU IN?
>> YOU KNOW, I DON’T KNOW.
I DO KNOW I ACTUALLY IN SOME
WAYS FEEL BAD FOR THESE PEOPLE
WHO BECOME SO CONSUMED WITH
THEIR HATRED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP
THAT YOU CAN ALMOST JUST SENSE
THE BITTERNESS THAT THEY HAVE
OF.
SO MUCH SO THAT LIZ CHENEY WAS
ACTUALLY RECORDING HER
COLLEAGUES.
ADAM SCHIFF TOOK A TEXT MESSAGE
THAT I HAD FORWARDED TO THE
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF,
CHANGED IT, ALTERED IT,
PRESENTED IT IN A FALSE WAY TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO THEY’RE REPORTING COLLEAGUES,
THEY’RE LYING TO PEOPLE ALL
BECAUSE THEY’RE DRIVEN BY THIS
ANIMOSITY TOWARDS PRESIDENT
TRUMP WHO I THINK WAS THE BEST
PRESIDENT WE HAVE HAD IN OUR,
CERTAINLY IN OUR LIFETIMES IN
DOING WHAT HE SAID HE WOULD DO.
I DON’T KNOW IF SHE’S THE ONE
DRIVING IT OR WHO’S DRIVING IT.
ALL I KNOW IS THEY HAVE YET TO
SERVE THE SUBPOENA.
WHEN WE GET IT, WE’LL TAKE A
LOOK AT IT, BUT YOU’VE GOT TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT A COMMITTEE THAT
OPERATES THE WAY THIS COMMITTEE
DOES AND HAS ENGAGED IN THE
CRAZY ACTIVITIES THAT THEY’VE
ENGAGED IN.
WE’VE U.S. GOT TO BE -- JUST GOT
TO BE REAL CONCERNED.
MARIA: MET ME JUST SAY WE
HAVEN’T HEARD A WORD OUT OF LIZ
CHENEY ON INFLATION, ON THE WIDE
OPEN BORDER, AND SOME OF THESE
ISSUES AROUND JOE BIDEN’S
BEHAVIOR HAS SOME OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES TALKING ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT.
I SPOKE WITH CONGRESSMAN GREG
MURPHY OVER ON FOX BUSINESS LAST
WEEK ON "MORNINGS WITH MARIA."
LISTEN TO WHAT GREG MURPHY SAYS
AS IT RELATES TO IMPEACHING JOE
BIDEN.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS HAD TWO
VERY CLEAR, VERY, VERY CLEAR
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES AGAINST THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NUMBER ONE, THE DEBACLE IN
AFGHANISTAN WHERE HE LITERALLY
SAID WE’RE NEVER GOING TO LEAVE
AMERICANS BEHIND, AND HE DID.
AND NUMBER TWO IS THE HANDLING
OF OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
YOU KNOW, LOOK, THIS IS BIDEN’S
WAR ON AMERICA.
MARIA: ARE YOU GOING TO MOVE TO
IMPEACH JOE BIDEN SHOULD YOU GET
THE MAJORITY IN NOVEMBER?
PLEASURE.
>> WELL, MARIA, FIRST THING’S
FIRST, WE’VE GOT TO WIN THE
MAJORITY.
WE’VE GOT TO CONTINUE TO TAKE
OUR MESSAGE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND TALK ABOUT ALL THE
CRAZY THINGS THEY’RE SEEING DONE
BY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THAT WILL BE A CONFERENCES
DECISION.
I DO THINK WHAT’S HAPPENING ON
THE BORDER IS AS WRONG AS IT
GETS, THE THE WAY THE EXIT FROM
AFGHANISTAN WAS JUST THE MOSTLY
KICK LOUSE THING THAT THAT WE’VE
SEEN -- RIDICULOUS THING THAT
WE’VE SEEN.
I DO THINK THAT’LL IS HAVE TO BE
A DECISION MADE BY THE ENTIRE
CONGRESS.
I THINK MAYORKAS SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED IN THAT CATEGORY TOO.
THIS GUY HAS SAID THE BORDER’S
SECURE UMPTEEN TIMES, AND WE ALL
KNOW IT’S NOT THE CASE.
HE HAS ALSO SAID HE IS
IMPLEMENTING EXECUTING HIS PLAN,
AND HIS PLAN IS INTENTIONAL,
BEING DONE INTENTIONALLY TO OPEN
OUR BORDER WIDE OPEN AND LET
EVERYBODY IN, AND THE POLICIES
THEY’VE CHANGED THAT WERE PART
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
SO I THINK MAYORKAS IS SOMEONE
NEED TO CONSIDER FOR IMPEACHMENT
AS WELL.
BUT THAT WILL BE A CONFERENCE
DECISION THAT WE’LL MAKE IF, IN
FACT, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DO
WHAT I THINK THEY’RE GOING TO
DO, WHICH IS PUT US IN THE
MAJORITY IN THIS FALL’S
ELECTION.
MARIA: KEVIN McCARTHY WAS ON
THE SHOW A FEW WEEKS AGO.
HE SAID, LOOK, WE’RE GOING TO DO
THINGS THAT ARE RIGHT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
A LOT OF DEBATE RECENTLY BECAUSE
OF LIZ CHENEY RECORDING
CONVERSATIONS WITH KEN
McCARTHY.
KEVIN McCARTHY.
DO YOU, CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN,
SUPPORT KEVIN McCARTHY AS
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE?
>> WE PICKED UP SEATS IN THE
LAST ELECTION, I THINK WE’RE
GOING TO PICK UP A FEW MORE, MY
ATTITUDE IS IF THE COACH THAT
GETS YOU TO THE SUPER BOWL, HE
GETS TO COACH THE GAME.
KEVIN HAS DONE A GREAT JOB
LEADING US LAST CONGRESS WHEN WE
HAD TO FOCUS ON THE ATTACKS ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
RIDICULOUS IMPEACHMENT EFFORT WE
SAW FROM ADAM SCHIFF AND THE
DEMOCRATS.
SO I THINK WE’RE GOING TO WIN,
AND I THINK HE’S GOING TO BE THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
AND I THINK IN TWO YEARS AFTER
THAT DONALD TRUMP’S GOING TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT, AND I THINK HE’S
GOING TO BE OUR NEXT PRESIDENT.
MARIA: ALL RIGHT.
WE’VE GOT A LOT TO WATCH FOR,
CONGRESSMAN.
AND THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
A LOT ON YOUR PLATE, AND WE ARE
CERTAINLY GOING TO COVER IT.
THANK YOU, SIR.
WE WILL SEE YOU SOON.